Hello everyone, my name is Martin Cousins. I'm going to be instructive for today and we're looking into introduction to Unreal Engine for programmers for Unreal 5.5
Brief kind of summary of the itinerary for today
First off we're going to start looking at project compilation and the kind of different configurations and deployments we can have
Then we're going to talk a little bit about modules
Which is kind of the key building blocks in a kind of code structure for how Unreal Engine puts a project together and just
Generally how an Unreal Engine project is structured then we're going to look a little bit at the Unreal build and header tool
Which are really important
Independent programs that are executed as part of either making a build of your project for
An editor or creating a packaged version of your game
Then we're going to talk a little bit about kind of the in engine minutia of things like the Unreal reflection system
then on to how
Components and actors are used with unreal what those ideas even mean how they're used what you can do with them
then we're going to go a bit into unreal's implementation of memory management and garbage collection and move on to the
life-cycles or objects and actors and things to be aware of when your programming systems that are using these things and
Last off we're going to finish off talking a little bit about blueprints
Which as we'll get to later is worth highlighting that is definitely not
Something that coders don't need to be aware of